(upbeat funky music)
- When this plane flies,
the only emission that
comes out of its tailpipe
is the same thing that's
in this glass, water.
It's because this plane is
powered by a hydrogen fuel cell.
Now I'll go into how
this works in a second,
but what's important is that
some in the aviation industry
believe that this technology,
hydrogen as a fuel,
could hold the key to
decarbonizing flight.
- What we need to do is eliminate
the climate impact of flying.
Hydrogen looks like it
can allow us to do that.
- But the physics and
economics around hydrogen
mean that the odds of your future flight
being hydrogen-powered is very dependent
on how far you plan on flying.
So is hydrogen flight here,
is it in the future, or
is it already too late?
Before we get into how
planes like this work,
it's important to consider
why the aviation industry
is thinking about hydrogen at all.
In 2021, aviation was responsible
for over 2% of global
energy-related CO2 emissions.
With flights pumping out
a little over 720 megatons
of CO2 into the atmosphere,
and before the pandemic
that was even higher,
at over 1,000 megatons.
Even though engines are
getting more fuel efficient
as global travel continues to recover,
aviation emissions are growing.
So in order to hit targets laid out
in the Paris Climate Accords,
various aviation groups such as IATA,
the International Air
Transport Association,
have set the industry an ambitious target,
net zero emissions by 2050.
While alternative fuels
like sustainable aviation fuel, or SAF,
could provide a pathway to net zero,
as the fuel still emits CO2,
hydrogen could provide a route
to absolutely zero emissions.
So how's it work?
One method is to use hydrogen combustion
where the hydrogen replaces jet fuel
and is ignited to drive the propellers.
Now, hydrogen is highly flammable.
So while that means you get
a lot of bang for your buck,
almost three times that
of jet fuel by weight,
it also means that its
use in aviation history
has been somewhat checkered.
(Hindenburg exploding)
So the other less fiery way
to use hydrogen in planes like this
is with a hydrogen fuel cell.
Much like a battery,
hydrogen fuel cells work
by creating a flow of
electrons around a circuit.
Hydrogen is fed into one
side of a cell, the anode,
and oxygen into the other, the cathode,
with a membrane sat between the two.
At the anode, the hydrogen
flows over a catalyst,
which separates the protons and electrons.
Now, the hydrogen protons
are able to pass through the
membrane to reach the oxygen,
but the electrons can't.
Instead, they have to make
their way around a circuit
and by doing so, power a motor
until they can reunite
with the hydrogen protons
and the oxygen to form H2O or water,
which along with heat
is the only emission that
comes from this whole process.
And it's that exact principle
that's happening in this plane behind me.
This is ZeroAvia's test plane,
a 19-seat aircraft,
which had its debut
hydrogen-powered flight
earlier this year.
I caught up with ZeroAvia's
CEO at the Paris Air Show.
- Today, we have four out
of the top 10 airlines
as our customers,
- Oh. right.
- already people reserve production slots
because they want to be the first.
- Right now, it's only
this left-hand engine
that's hydrogen-powered,
but once the company completes testing
it has plans to develop engines
to be able to carry 19 passengers
around 300 nautical miles by 2025.
Two other small startups
pursuing hydrogen flight,
are US-based Universal Hydrogen
who were flown a similar
plane to ZeroAvia,
and German-based H2FLY.
- We started in 2006
to develop this kind of technology.
At the moment,
we are in the seventh
generation of powertrains,
and I think the technology is today here,
- [Narrator] But it's
not just small startups
or small aircraft,
one major plane manufacturer
has thrown its weight behind
hydrogen in a big way, Airbus.
- We're hoping to introduce
a hydrogen-powered aircraft in 2035,
with zero CO2,
so we're not just talking about net zero,
we're talking about absolute zero.
- Airbus has plans
for three different
commercial hydrogen planes,
a turbofan, a propeller-powered plane,
and a longer range
further into the future,
blended wing design.
- Our view is that 2035
is not soon enough,
and we've got an urgency
to be bringing these
technologies to the market.
- But while Airbus may
be backing hydrogen,
Boeing on the other hand,
appears less certain about
its role in powering aircraft.
- We've learned a lot with hydrogen,
and we've flown
six different forms of
airplanes on hydrogen.
So we just think that its
impact on airplanes, airports,
and pipelines is greater,
and therefore, it won't help us as soon
as some of these other solutions
that are less impactful.
- [Narrator] Yeah.
- [Chris] And if the goal is 2050,
we've gotta work on the things
that'll help us the fastest.
- So why is that?
Well, while hydrogen
might be one of the most abundant
elements in the Universe,
on Earth, it's almost always attached
to something else, like
oxygen to form water.
To isolate it requires
using an electrolyzer,
which is the reverse of a fuel cell,
and that requires energy.
Now, in order for hydrogen fuel
to be considered carbon neutral,
known as green hydrogen,
the energy source that you
use in that electrolyzer,
also has to be renewable, like solar.
And right now, green hydrogen is expensive
and kind of hard to come by.
- The different decarbonized energies
that we're looking at
are more expensive than kerosene is today.
So there's going to be
an increase in price,
in cost of the airlines,
and that's likely to have
an impact on ticket prices.
- Then there's the infrastructure
around delivering it.
While hydrogen electrolyzers can be set up
pretty much anywhere,
the amount needed to power
aviation around the globe
would require investment,
potentially more than
other sustainable fuels
that can be piped into airports
using the same infrastructure as jet fuel.
- We expect that in Europe,
we will have 10 to 12
billion of Euros investment
just to replace the carnosine
infrastructure with hydrogen.
- And then there's the plane itself.
While hydrogen may be
lighter than jet fuel,
it's actually less energy-dense
and takes more space than the
equivalent amount of jet fuel.
That's why the windows on Airbus rendered
on their hydrogen aircraft stop here
because all of this would
be used as a fuel tank.
Obviously, less seats
means less passengers,
which potentially means less revenue.
What's more, even with all that space,
right now it's still only enough hydrogen
to do short flights,
meaning that trans-oceanic routes
aren't currently possible on hydrogen,
unless it's a small ocean.
- To really unleash the power of hydrogen,
to really have a huge benefit
even to go long range with hydrogen,
we have to rethink the way we fly.
We have to rethink the shape of the planes
- And therein lies the problem.
When it comes to larger planes,
it could already be too late
for hydrogen to take off.
The planes that are on sale today
by the likes of Boeing and Airbus
have a backlog of roughly six
years depending on the plane.
Those planes are then in service
for an average of around 20 years.
And that means that the planes
that are being sold today
are the planes that
we'll be using in 2050,
and looking around,
none of them are hydrogen compatible.
- So hydrogen in its raw
form isn't compatible
with those existing aircraft.
And that's why sustainable aviation fuel
is really important.
- There's also a chance
that it could stay that way.
See, that target set by IATA and others
was for net zero by
2050, not absolute zero.
And if airlines achieve their
net zero aims using SAF,
there's questions around
whether they would then
choose to invest millions
into renewing their entire
fleet to be hydrogen planes,
and they've technically,
already hit their environmental targets.
All this means that while you may see
a greater number of hydrogen planes
in the skies over the next few years
unless you're taking a
relatively short trip,
you could be waiting a long time
before you step foot
aboard a hydrogen plane.
(upbeat music)